hey guys justin and Tom here with a
gamespot news break down Microsoft has
finally come out with an official price
drop for the xbox one it is now a
four-hundred-dollar system that we've
been talking about this for months the
most important thing that Microsoft
needed to do to be competitive with the
PlayStation 4 was to officially drop the
price and they finally done that I mean
they had to cut out connect we're not
gonna we're gonna have a connect less
system but it is now when you go into
stores you see a four-hundred-dollar
system and I think that is that is huge
especially doing this before e3 yeah I
think I mean it shows that they didn't
do as well as I wanted with Martian
titanfall and that they're still kind of
struggling and they need to gain ground
somehow though I do think you overstate
the price a little bit because in March
we did see the bundle 450 with with
titanfall and it still didn't move
systems so even even with that price
drop it didn't work that much and it's
like so now I mean now that has to be
more drastic but they still have to
actually compete and prove why you have
to buy this system I'm saying it didn't
move systems it it's still sold system
and I think that you a novel you're
under summate under estimating the
importance of walking into a store and
seeing a four-hundred-dollar price point
I mean with the bundles yeah to us I
mean we're savvy consumers and we know
that but with a game and like that this
is essentially cheaper at four hundred
fifty dollars but it's not you still see
that four hundred fifty dollar right boy
now it's 399 it's comparable to the
PlayStation 4 and I think that's the
most important thing they could have
done they've made this at a price parity
point so 11 things I still have gone
against them is the PlayStation 4 is
more powerful and it's the same price so
that that seemed Chris consumers they
still know about this don't know the
xbox one doesn't do 1080p they still
know about all of this that's not true
running around I mean it rarely does
1080p it can do 1080p and I mean the
performance is negligible like
especially at this point between the
PlayStation 4 and the Xbox one what
they're able to put out in terms of
processing like I if everything is equal
do you think consumers are gonna go
towards the more powerful console or the
less powerful console I mean Xbox has
lost the perception battle yeah when God
variable or putting out games in there
like when you can go into a store and
like well which game is when I when the
guy selling a game can say like well
this one's a 1080p and 60 frames per
second
the xbox one is a 900 feet I mean you're
a consumer is not actually going to be
able to tell the difference but it's
such an easy quick talking point yeah
1080p 60 frames per second versus
anything less than that but here's why I
think this is actually unfortunate i can
take the side that I'm sad about this
they connect differentiated like the
connector is a cool piece of hardware
that was way underutilized and now it's
an option that's kind of going to go the
way of the virtual boy like it's not
going to be used it's going to be like
how that connects the original Kinect
sold 15 million out of 70 million xbox
360's out there like it's not gonna get
utilizing I'm kind of sad the Microsoft
didn't justify the existence of that
system as opposed to this like pulling
it out completely in a way the spool
force Microsoft and force developers to
make a reason to get the car today or
are they just going to say what if I
don't make it like we already know that
Fantasia from harmonix is in development
but how many new developers are going to
say I want to make a Kinect game knowing
that I have to justify a hundred-dollar
accessory for it well and that's worth
the interest for developers will do that
that's where Microsoft can come in and
go we want to incentivize you even more
like we want to make sure that you're
making some kind of sounds gonna keep
pouring money on this lost cause like
that's what your philosophy is here but
it's not a lost cause I mean you're
you're also saying that that there's
nothing else to different sheets the
xbox one it and the interface is
something that differentiate I mean it
in in essence there's not really
anything that differentiates a PC from a
ps4 and xbox one they all play games in
and in a lot of ways they play very
similar games but the platform that you
experience them on is very different the
way that you have twitch integration
differs greatly xbox one you know having
the ability to switch between different
applications which way are some people
very important those that stuff becomes
a lot more difficult if you don't to
connect by the way it's not easy to use
skype for instance and it's not easy to
do snapping if you don't have that so I
mean Microsoft is losing a lot of its
identity I mean with getting rid of the
kinect i don't think that they're
sacrificing of I I don't think they're
sacrificing their identity to do this
but I think it's important that they
finally gave consumers a choice this is
something they needed to do and we've
been telling that they need to do it for
a while I don't think that you've been
on a pulpit saying no no you should
totally keep the Kinect and keep
no I thought they should have gotten rid
of it cuz i think it's insane to charge
me a hundred dollars for something
that's worthless in my eyes but i would
have rather than justified it and pulled
it well we also had some other really
big news from there my relay today's me
and this one does affect you personally
netflix hulu all of those services that
previously you had to be behind the xbox
live gold paywall to use are now free to
everybody and really that's something
that should have been in there from the
beginning yes it was insane and now
they're giving away Xbox one's game for
gold starting in June you're gonna get a
free copy of Max and the magic marker or
wherever the sequel was and you're going
to get another indie game that I can't
remember forget it you're getting there
getting free stuff they're trying to
chase after what Sony is doing and I'm
hoping that it does match up with the
PlayStation Plus because they they have
some work did it because the gold was a
Wayne worst value for a long time and
now this this it meets puts it at parity
and what's that something microsoft
needs to do and getting to that same
level I mean that only that makes things
more interesting because at some point
so it has to step it up again and
whether that's gonna be sony or whether
that's gonna be Microsoft that's pretty
exciting and I think that's the kind of
thing that will save me three like what
who's gonna take it to the next level
who's gonna give you a massage when you
buy your PlayStation 4 like you just
have a guy I don't want that I don't
want that I don't want that so yeah so
we have a price parity we have online
parody and now it's all about the games
and III is going to be all about the
games we're not going to be talking
about this price drop and about a month
when the word III we're gonna be talking
about what games did they show on the
stage and and that's really exciting
that Microsoft has so much confidence in
what they're gonna have to show they're
like we're gonna get this price drop out
of there this is an e3 level
announcement and they're basically
saying we're just going to drop this
right now because III is all about the
games and that's kind of excited now I
am really excited to have to have
platinum exclusive I've heard it here
first well we'll be talking a lot more
about this xbox one price drop and news
leading up to e3 right here on gamespot
com
you